[Música]
aquí comienza ellas hoy el programa
feminista de France 24 en febrero del
2022 Colombia despenalizó El aborto
hasta la semana 24 un logro de la lucha
feminista pero en concreto del
movimiento causa justa que consiguió que
los tribunales atendieran una demanda
judicial para despenalizar la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo en
abril el colectivo publicó un libro
sobre toda la batalla judicial y las
historias en carne propia contada a
cinco voces de lideresas y demandantes
este es el inicio de una nueva batalla
la de difundir los Derechos adquiridos
para las colombianas y para el sur
global vamos a comenzar con la revisión
de nuestra periodista Alba Santana
hace poco más de un año Colombia dio un
paso adelante en los derechos
reproductivos de las personas que
estantes despenalizó el aborto hasta la
semana 24 del embarazo en un día teñido
por gritos abrazos y lágrimas de las
colectivas feministas
hoy en día estoy en un país en el que
las mujeres pueden decidir libremente
hasta las 24 semanas y nunca pensé que
fuera a ser parte de ese cambio cambió
la conversación en el ámbito médico se
empezó a hablar más de la autonomía de
las mujeres entendió que aquí no se
trataba de qué pensaba el médico que era
mejor sino de que quería la mujer para
ella misma y para su vida pero cómo se
llegó hasta allá antes de febrero del
2022 solo se podía abortar bajo tres
causales violación a malformación del
feto incompatible con la vida o riesgo
para la salud de la mujer entre los
movimientos feministas que lucharon para
cambiar esta realidad destaca uno causa
justa y sobre todo a la demanda que
impusieron por vía judicial para
eliminar el delito del aborto del Código
Penal colombiano alegando que el aborto
con el sistema de las tres causales
violaba los derechos de las personas
gestantes atentaba contra la autonomía
reproductiva no reconocía la ciudadanía
plena y acentuaba las inequidades para
acceder un aborto seguro y es que bajo
ese sistema una media de 400 personas
que estantes terminaban en la cárcel al
año con penas de 16 hasta 54 meses algo
contra lo que lucharon y ganaron en los
tribunales hubo una gran capacidad de
organización y creo que eso fue clave
para la victoria un hito histórico que
colocó a Colombia a la vanguardia de la
región y que abre puertas para las
mujeres de hoy día y las futuras
generaciones la conversación es con
Catalina Martínez coral feminista
colombiana y directora regional para
América Latina y el Caribe del centro de
derechos reproductivos además de
integrante del movimiento causa justa y
una de las demandantes de este fallo
histórico que despenalizó parcialmente
el aborto en Colombia también está en
ella soy Sandra Mazo quien es también
integrante del movimiento de causa justa
y directora de la organización feminista
católica por el derecho a decidir en
Colombia integrante Además del grupo
asesor de sociedad civil de ONU mujeres
Colombia Muchas gracias a nuestras
invitadas bienvenidas a ellas hoy
Muchísimas gracias por la invitación muy
honradas de poder estar acá y compartir
esta experiencia No pues honrados
nosotros aquí en ellas hoy por poder
contar lo que ha sido este marco legal
que se convierte en uno de los más
garantistas en términos de derechos del
aborto y aquí después de la experiencia
de leer el libro Sandra comienzo con
usted me llama mucho la atención ese
gran énfasis que se hace dentro de esta
lucha en la importancia de que el aborto
salga de La regulación del Código Penal
y que pase a ser regulado por otro tipo
de autoridades como sistema de salud y
al final Pues por la decisión de las
propias mujeres Comencemos por ahí bueno
no pues ese fue el reto y el objetivo de
causa justa Y es que el gran problema
del aborto es que esté en el código
penal definitivamente no es
criminalizando y condenando a las
mujeres como se van a garantizar
derechos y por eso para nosotras ha sido
un ejercicio no solamente de Li y de y
de ponerlo en el marco normativo sino
también pensarlo en el cambio social y
cultural Pues porque necesitamos una
comprensión mucho más amplia y más
integral de lo que significa para las
mujeres la decisión de abortar cuando se
enfrentan a un embarazo no deseado por
eso situarlo como un servicio y un
derecho a la salud es fundamental para
garantizar el derecho a decir y la
autonomía reproductiva de las mujeres
aunque esto es muy clave y viene de una
lucha en la que ustedes me van a
corregir sería además de 15 años a
través de diferentes organizaciones y
que se vino a condensar en el movimiento
causa justa para los sectores más
conservadores de la población colombiana
y latinoamericana esto aún pues está
escrito en chino no Y la forma más
efectiva es lo penal para regular
cualquier Norma o cualquier decisión en
el país quisiera por eso Catalina traer
algunas de las cifras que motivan o
argumentan que no debería estar en el
código penal no y por lo que es una gran
Victoria entonces hablando por ejemplo
de las mujeres más vulnerables que no
tienen acceso a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo quisiera pedirle
algunas cifras sobre la criminalización
de las mujeres y pues Quiénes son las
más afectadas Claro que sí mira lo que
nosotras nos dispusimos a hacer cuando
empezamos a documentar Cómo era el
acceso al aborto bajo el modelo de
causales nos dimos cuenta que las
mujeres seguían enfrentando múltiples
barreras para Acceder al servicio no y
que para darte una cifra muy específica
del uno al 12% de abortos que se hacían
en el país se hacían en el sistema de
salud lo que quiere decir que imagínate
el universo de mujeres que estaban
recurriendo a servicios de aborto en la
inseguridad en este país durante 15 años
que duró el sistema de causales también
supimos que la criminalización y las
denuncias contra mujeres no bajaron bajo
el modelo de causales sino que al
contrario empezaron a subir Durante los
años lo que quiere decir que hoy en día
tenemos más mil procesos abiertos del
2006 hasta ahora contra mujeres que
habían buscado poder acceder a un
servicio de salud como el aborto
Entonces esto para decir que sacar el
delito aborto del Código Penal es
fundamental porque el aborto es un
servicio de salud y no tiene ningún
sentido que un servicio de salud esté
regulado en un código penal que lo que
está haciendo es criminalizar a las
mujeres y poniéndoles barreras
adicionales para que puedan acceder a un
servicio de salud me llama la atención
que se cita entre muchísimos ejemplos El
ejemplo de Canadá donde no hay
penalización al aborto y esto lo que ha
producido es menos abortos en el tiempo
y cuando se producen abortos que se dan
en las primeras etapas de gestación así
que pues esto es un poco para ir
cambiando el Main setting de lo que
podría pasar en Colombia si se siguiera
avanzando en estos derechos y bueno
hablar por supuesto de que siempre son
una parte importante de las condenas las
que recaen sobre menores y Menores en
condición de vulnerabilidad y sobre todo
Sandra que esto no evitó que siguieran
siendo las niñas madres por montones en
Colombia como es una realidad
latinoamericana la cifra en 2020 más de
4.000 menores de 14 años dieron a luz
cómo puede ser esto si están protegidas
por el modelo anterior de las tres
causales sino es que el absurdo del
embarazo no deseado y parte de la
violencia que esto significa para las
mujeres es una cosa desbordada y y
incomprendida social política y
jurídicamente o sea el gran problema que
nos enfrentamos y por eso nos animó como
causa justa fue que se está imponiendo
maternidades no deseadas y se está
pensando que el sino o el destino único
de las mujeres es la maternidad entonces
pues nosotras situamos una conversación
Pública que es más allá incluso de la
propia Norma y tiene un alcance mucho
más que la propia sentencia y es abordar
el asunto de las violencias
estructurales de condenar a las mujeres
a maternidades no deseadas o sea y esta
sentencia la grandeza también que tiene
es que nos invita y a la sociedad Ya la
ya en esta reconfiguración nos plantea
que las maternidades a partir también de
esta sentencia son maternidades deseadas
o sea el tiempo también que dio la corte
en la sentencia lo que nos lo que le
plantea a las mujeres es que van a tener
también un tiempo para que sus
decisiones sean libres informadas que
puedan Acceder al sistema de salud en
condiciones dignas de calidad sin
condenas sin estigmas y que no le tengan
que pedir permiso a nadie para tomar la
decisión de interrumpir voluntariamente
de manera voluntaria en el embarazo
entonces pues sí tiene que indignarnos
que las niñas estén condenadas a
maternidades no deseadas cuando deben
ser y no madres y también pues las
mujeres en su conjunto que están
enfrentando embarazos no deseados
también hay que empezar que la sociedad
entienda que la maternidad tiene que ser
una opción no una obligación y partiendo
por supuesto de que pareciera obvio pero
no lo es que una niña menor de 14 años
que es madre es el resultado de una
violación No claro es violencia
es ilegal a todas luces ahora han
insistido mucho también Catalina en el
libro en que las tres causales no son
efectivas no son eficaces y lo que han
hecho irónicamente es imponer a veces
más barreras para las mujeres
rápidamente Por qué no y porque cambia
tanto el marco legal ahora con esta
despenalización hasta las 24 semanas
Claro que sí porque en el modelo de
causales a lo que nos encontraba en
frente a lo que nos encontrábamos es a
Qué es las decisiones frente así una
persona podía acceder o no a una
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
eran tomadas por una tercera persona
esta tercera persona normalmente era el
profesional médico o la profesional
médica que estaba atendiendo a esta
persona y la valoración de Qué es un
riesgo para la vida y que es un riesgo
para la salud sigue siendo muy subjetiva
inclusive dentro de Los profesionales de
la salud y esa subjetidades además están
informadas muchas veces por los
estereotipos que siguen existiendo en
nuestra sociedad no Entonces sí tenemos
un estigma frente a un servicio de salud
como el aborto Entonces hasta qué punto
se valora un riesgo para la vida y la
salud de una de una persona o sea la
respuesta evidente de cómo se estaba
haciendo es precisamente esta cifra que
tú nos decías cómo puede ser posible que
4.000 niñas menores de 14 años hayan
dado a luz en un año en este país cuando
esas niñas Sí o sí tenían que haber
podido Acceder al aborto por la causal
violación sexual por qué Porque la
valoración era el aborto es malo no
pueden acceder a esto porque es algo que
está malo hay un estigma estereotipo
alrededor de esto Entonces qué pasa
cuando pasamos del modelo de causales a
un modelo de aborto libre que es lo que
tenemos en este momento en Colombia la
el modelo decisional pasa a ser de la
mujer y de la persona que está buscando
este servicio de salud y es ahí donde
realmente el el chip cambia porque
estamos decidiendo sobre un servicio de
salud al que queremos acceder pero
adicional a eso estamos decidiendo sobre
nuestro cuerpo sobre nuestro proyecto de
vida sobre sobre nuestros sueños
inclusive no O sea realmente volvemos a
recuperar esa autonomía sobre nuestro
cuerpo es autonomía sobre algo que es
tan íntimo Y eso pues nos hace ser sin
lugar a dudas más libres y pues
ciudadanas de primera categoría en esta
democracia ya para el cierre Sandra y
Catalina Yo quisiera leer un pequeño
apartado que hizo parte además de la
declaración que ustedes hicieron el día
que esta sentencia salió favorable
nuestra causa es la Libertad Libertad
para decidir Libertad para no
embarazarnos Libertad para abortar de
manera segura y oportuna según nuestras
íntimas razones y convicciones Libertad
para decidir sobre nuestros cuerpos sin
intervención de terceros Libertad para
abortar sin La amenaza de ir a la cárcel
a las dos Muchas gracias muchas gracias
y para el cierre pues hemos elegido en
ellas hoy en esta ocasión un momento que
también fue histórico dentro de la
movilización causa justa y es el
lanzamiento de un video que todavía
resuena en las calles un reggaetón por
los derechos sexuales y reproductivos
no nos hace criminales verdaderos
criminales quienes violan libertades
escogernos un pecado ni tampoco un
delito libre decido libre decido saca
tus rosarios de nuestros ovarios y de
cómo decido irme como llamando en la
calle reportándome con la bandera verde
modo resistencia no contiene no somos
histéricas somos históricas no somos
histéricas